The only value of x that makes this equation true is x equals 3. Great work for
getting that one correct. First we want to get each radical on one side of the
equal sign. So we can add this radical to both sides of the equation. Now that
each radical is on either side of the equal sign we can square both sides to
undo these square roots. So on the left, we'll just be left with the radicand,
6x minus 7. And on the right, we'll be left with this expression, 2x plus 5.
Next, we just want to solve this linear equation for the value of x. So we
subtract 2x from both sides and then, add positive 7 to both sides. This will
leave us with 4x equals 12 and then, we divide both sides by 4 to get x equals
3. To double-check our result, we'll plug in x equals 3 into the original
equation. When we check x equals 3, we'll get this expression on the left,
which evaluates to root 11 minus root 11, which equals 0. Our answer checks so
we can use this as our solution set, x just equals positive 3.